[Music]
I have before me the ominous task of
making this presentation really
interesting with a topic which is going
to sound like a what are those
missing pieces for workflow or
automation to happen with AI and I'm
going to tell you really an Enterprise
story is it dry is it just going to be
about now I'm going to find out who took
my lunch sandwich we'll see um and you
know as I Was preparing for this talk
and I realized in the schedule that this
is going to be just after lunch I
thought I should start off with a joke
and since for all our daily needs we go
to AI tools I tried to go to a AI tool
for a joke
and they really suck I couldn't find one
decent joke if you can tell me a good
joke about you know using AI for your
real world Enterprise needs I'd be happy
to squeeze it in right
now uh clicker doesn't
work can someone help me oh okay yep so
the graph looks a little different from
all the graphs that I've been been
seeing this
morning we took this journey in our
worlds in our Enterprise worlds um as we
explored but before I dive into this I
think I should do an introduction I'm
shisha I've come all the way from
Bangalore to tell you the story that I
see unfolding around me not just in
Thompson Reuters where I work trying to
bring AI to my um to my um you know
teams and um different business
processes but also the same story that I
hear at meetups and you know um
different community events where where I
meet AI
practitioners um everyone started off
trying to democratize the use of
generative AI back in 20123 we have
something called as open arena in uh
Thompson Reuters very similar to your
you know um playground where you can try
different large language models this is
where it truly came home to um almost
everybody in an Enterprise to start
using generative AI for their workflows
further along we got onto the rag um and
you know prompt engineering World pretty
quickly we looked at um automating
various knowledge driven tasks with the
use of rag and very soon we were
answering questions um at the Enterprise
level on what is the
ROI further along in 2024 we started to
play with tools and Frameworks and we
heralded the rise of the agents we are
now here where we're looking at
automating entire workflows with the use
of AI SL agents and not just one task at
a time right we are looking at a future
where we want to reimagine business
processes because just automating a task
seems redundant
okay so what what do we mean by workflow
Automation and what I've got here is a
very typical workflow for almost any
company that's putting software out
there customer calls you calls your
service desk report a billing issue an
invoice issue or a product feature not
working as expected your customer
support um is going to take the call
they are probably using rag to of answer
that question already or they may be
looking at you know internal tickets or
connecting with um you know uh their uh
hierarchy to see if the answer can if
the answer can be given and if no
answers are found they then you know
report a ticket to the it Ops teams
right the internal it Ops teams do the
level two support and they're looking at
you know launching investigations to
support this further along if this
doesn't work you've got your engineering
teams doing the L3 L4 support and a fix
is likely going to be identified with
the use of various observability tools
scripts are launched to you know create
that new build tests regression tests
integration tests are launched and
finally you've got either the bug fixed
or the billing question answered your
tickets are updated and SLA is met
needless to say all of you can spot so
many of these tasks that can be
automated with the use of Agents but you
know is automating each task the way we
want to do this is there something that
can be done differently in reimagining
this
workflow we are there we're trying to
reimagine this
workflow um here's a slightly different
take let's look at
um a workflow where content is getting
created right it starts off with authors
or content specialist perhaps
identifying an alert or a trigger that's
going to launch that content workflow
you then have maybe approvals to say yes
go ahead do your research find out what
we want to write about this and then
you've got you know content getting
created with research being done and
subsequently your editors and your um
associate editors and reviewers
reviewing that content if it's you know
very critical content you you will
probably have several rounds of this
reviews and eventually the finalized
content goes to the publisher which then
you know the the publishing teams then
launch their own formatting styling
related workflows and eventually the
content is published here too you will
realize that so many of these tasks can
be done by AI can be done by agents and
of course humans being in the approval
flow but here again something seems a
Miss should we stick to the same design
of the workflow or should we be doing
this a little
differently okay so that's that's where
we are we want to be able to reimagine
these workflows because it's a new world
because we have new capabilities with
these
Technologies um and not just plug in
capabilities into an existing business
process right but we're stuck
we're stuck we are um missing certain
parts of that
reimagination so what are we
missing the first thing that we're
missing is
connectors um I I spoke to few of the um
you know the Stalls uh yesterday and a
common theme was how around providing a
good AI agentic solution you always
needed that layer which connected to
your current it systems right and and
connectors are a very very much a
missing part of reimagining these
business
processes um I also want to say that you
know I come from a world
where um you know technology is not
altogether new we've been you know we've
been doing AI we've been doing NLP for
several decades as Thompson Reuters and
even even in the different companies
that um uh that developers come from in
the different meetups and communities
that I attend they are also supporting
it systems of some of the you know
different technology companies of our
world Believe It or Not
71% of Fortune 500 companies still use
Mainframe 68% of the world's it
production workloads still run on
Mainframe right and some of your major
credit card um transactions still happen
on the
Mainframe which means we are that
distant right like that technology
Spectrum if you were to measure from the
main frame to to an agentic workflow how
do we connect these worlds right and so
that's one of one of our major stumbling
blocks I believe where you know how do
you connect the worlds of the technology
um stable technology Stacks that exist
with um with with with the power of AI
agentic workflows the second thing is
something that um I struggle with as I
take new ideas to different stakeholders
and I see you know several startups whom
I meet on a regular basis them
struggling as well it comes back to the
question of Roi it comes to the question
of you know um
reliability right how will I be sure
that my agent will be able to perform
and often with stakeholders and you know
from from a business impact standpoint
it's a zero or one call right am I going
to continue to need to have to pay
manual hours or can I consider that not
needed anymore if I'm going to pay for
the agent AI agent right and so
reliability becomes a big factor and a
stumbling block for us the third thing
that we finding missing as practitioners
is to have Visionaries who are able to
reimagine this world with us it's um you
know as a practitioner as somebody who
is deeply entrenched in AI you can only
go that far in reimagining this world
you need the subject matter experts you
need the Specialists from that specific
domain to sort of do this together with
them to be able to you know reimagine
your business
processes the the fourth thing that you
know we need and I'm sure many of you
will agree based on conversations that
I've had is we need a certain level of
standardization right we need to be able
to say this is how agents will be built
this is how they are packaged this is
how they're deployed it's too nent yet
um you know in a in a established Tech
ecosystem to say uh this we are going to
replace these these bits with
agents data and systems for an agent to
truly you know um get its full power we
need to give it access to context the
context is today distributed across
different it systems Business Systems it
is probably um partially located in logs
it is probably there in um chat messages
or you know it tickets and you know
different um you know different sty Lord
systems right sometimes which are spread
across different parts of the
organization and so bringing them
together and even identifying which of
these systems will have what and how do
you correlate a single transaction
across Ross These systems becomes often
a stumbling part of you know getting the
AI in the sixth thing is one that you
know I've I personally feel very
strongly about is creating a
collaborative
ux agents are going to be assistants so
what is the role of the human defining
that and creating systems in which
humans can support the work of the
agents and vice versa is I think a very
important part of um creating creating
those workflows and so what makes sense
from a collaborative ux is something
that you know I'm waiting to hear from
from any of you fresh ideas on
right AI governance we we saw um in one
of the talks about how different parts
of different aspects of security testing
go down into parts of your agentic
workflows and and so you know aspects of
your AI governance which we established
all this while around ethics and
responsibility how do you translate that
into different levels of your agent
architecture
right the next thing is control we still
want to give the human control we want
to have certain steps which are
deterministic and certain steps which
the agent can control on its own or you
know how how do you balance that um need
for for control uh between between the
agent and the human and give the human
the right um you know right time to act
and finally what is the life cycle for
the agent All of You Have You Know
spoken about that exponential growth of
um evolution in our space how do we
bring the capability the latest
capability into what we've already got
deployed and that one that's ever
changing so that that's what I had to
share um um we are just at the start a
lot of good work from all of you I'm
waiting to bridge from the world that
I'm seeing around me to the world that I
come from and so happy to have your
questions and ideas suggestions feedback
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]